have fun see ya my kid asked me what
bitcoin is what's your answer to that
bitcoin I would tell them bitcoin is an
electronic currency no I wouldn't I
would I would tell them that bitcoin is
a series of coats and every code is
different and if you have one code then
you have a part of Bitcoin and that code
is only your's and is completely
different than every other code so we
know how many codes you have and how
many codes other people have and you can
trade you can send your code to other
people's codes and then they have an
electronic oh man
that case dude I can take a few that
could be confused
I got it two codes but then I got really
confused
I think bitcoin is a code with a bunch
of other codes and then I thought I
started thinking about money and how
money is divisible by sense
all right ever oh my god I got lost I
hadn't thought about this before but I
would say it's again it's digital gold
there's two words you have to then talk
about what does digital mean great
question digital means it's comprised of
symbols it does not mean electronic the
first example of what we want to call
digital is words if we use words we are
being digital conceptually digital when
we use letters we're being digital and
so what bitcoin is is us like you set a
code what you meant by code was a word a
long string of numbers what does the
analog mean when I give you a hug it's
analog but if I tell you I love you it's
digital yeah
good god yeah
by the way bitcoin can be done with
paper all over the world with no
internet and no electricity just like
its symbols and then gold is rarity and
so that's a separate that's a separate
question of people have to get their
head around cool it's valuable cuz
bababa it's only valuable at the pray at
the market price because of how rare it
is and the value checks the rarity on
earth and there is a utility value but
the utility value is a tiny fraction of
its market value market is what a human
mind wants to pay and so there's many
conductors that are as good as gold that
ore is cheap
so if you can understand that rarity
means value card collectors understand
this all people who collect know it and
so they would get rarity as value a lot
of people can't get to rarity as value
even when you explain it they won't
they'll still be like no gold is it's
got a value it's all my ring it's it's
in there it's it's gotta have value it's
at the store with that big sticker price
could you explain to me if everyone was
walking around with their Bitcoin codes
on paper so how that would work would we
we be checking the codes manually but I
can't check the coach of someone across
the other side of the planet that's what
the great thing is about the block or
whatever together all of the machines
are checking the codes together how
would you do that if y'all have no paper
you're getting to the end of the
explanation but the simple cool answer
there is you shout it so if we were
actually doing this world or example
there would be Bitcoin nodes which are
people that are just sitting around
listening and if you want to say if I
want to send Bitcoin for me to you I
have to shout it and you have to shout
it loud enough that somebody hears when
they hear they shout and it reshapes all
around Earth there the record keepers
that guy down the street keeps track of
the Bitcoin not me my voice can move it
by uttering the correct symbol sequence
well and then we could and then and then
to make that easier we could use phones
and then once we're using phones we
could just easily
two computers animating right and that
is you know that's what a note is I
didn't ever I've never understood what a
note is and now you just explained to it
it's the guy you know in front of the
corner store and he's the he's the town
you know gossiper or whatever and you go
and tell him all the news and he gossips
it Deborah when everyone's checking the
everyone's checking the records in the
town who slept with you and who is stole
from you and who ripped off whatever
else I don't know yeah and you know
everyone's records and then that's what
you said were rare codes your mother
you're getting at the point which is you
have symbol sequences that are rare that
only belong to the Bitcoin chain if you
want one of those symbol sequences you
got to pay for it or you got to beg
someone to send it to you well I'm kind
of interested in your final answer
what the hell you would tell your
digital gold you would tell your child
digital gold what the hell is gold what
the hell is digital me my kids won't
know what digital means the only way is
to teach them those words first and then
they're ready to know about Bitcoin and
that's back to what you said earlier
which is there's some questions kids we
know aren't ready for it you know with
kids if they when they ask you something
they're not ready for
if you can't literally translate it the
best you do is you say the adult words
knowing they won't know it and you're
just like yeah too bad sorry buddy
all kids listen to is your tone so when
you say those big words are that nervous
hyper hyper nervous oh no I don't want
to talk about this panic attack tone
that's the kids oh good I know sex is
that terrible thing that I should never
get involved in it's a causative
relationship this it's special touching
mommy's not these countries especially
in that it's very special but it's only
for married so there you go the answer
is Bitcoin maybe there's a better answer
I'd have to think about it more but I
would use this simple a tall answer
digital gold and then you just got to go
into both those words it
so that's so easy once you tell me it's
the node the idea what it unnoticed
sounds so foreign and then once you're
like it's a guy on the corner shouting
out stuff and Oh God
[Music]
you